c'est devant le siège de mahdia net au
lamentin qu'une partie des salariés
grévistes affiliés à la cdmt s'est
retrouvé ce matin pas d'esclandre ni
d'ambiances sonores mais une simple
présence pour marquer le désaccord entre
direction et employés des employés qui
protestent d'abord contre le
licenciement annoncé de 6 d'entre eux
ils de les licences et pourquoi parce
que déjà parce que c'est la prime la
prime qu'un petit peu trop au goût bulli
il ya aussi les nao
il ya beaucoup de pression parce que le
chef d'exploitation qu'on embauche et ça
fait moins de trois ans on fait beaucoup
de pression sur nos sur les salariés
beaucoup de choses
nous avons tenté de joindre le directeur
toute la journée en vain mais selon le
syndicat il a accepté d'entamer les
négociations depuis la mi journée
quant au mouvement il continue car dans
son préavis
la cdmt avait annoncé une grève
reconductible